there was a point in my life where I
just didn't want to know anything about
it you know like before I embrace Islam
there was a point where I was just
trying to I was even having like Swiss
suicidal thoughts you know I wanted to
kill myself because there was no point
in this life you know all you know
having girls having money having you
know like parties and all that stuff but
yeah that was same thing you know and
back coming in Mexico you know I'm
coming from a Catholic background in
Mexico and you know like when i came to
united states i ended up you know like
the Catholicism was not the same so i
started to go to the christian church
you know but that was not enough so when
I postre my face in the ground I was
like totally you know all the prayers I
postre my face in the ground and I said
the one that created me just the one
that created me just guide me just guide
me I'm giving you my life back to you
the one that gave me the life I give you
my life back used for your own purpose I
don't really care who you are where you
are I've been looking for you in the
Catholics I look for you in the
Christians I don't care if you're with
the Buddhist with the with the you know
I don't care if you're with the Buddhist
with the Hindu so whatever you are just
guy me if you don't if you don't guide
me I just going to take my life because
it's not worth it just just take my life
I'm giving it to you for your own
purpose and after da hamdulillah I
started seeing like a lot of changes in
my life a lot of blessings and to be
honest with you I never never thought
that I will be Muslim I never thought
that I would that it will be Islam and
don't forget subscribe right now